Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Quando sono arrivato in azienda,
tanto tempo fa,
la prima cosa che ho visto
è una sorta di scatola misteriosa
in cui qualcosa entrava,
e da cui qualcosa usciva.
Ma soprattutto, all’interno della quale
qualcosa accadeva.
Certo era qualche generazione
di computer fa
- quello era il mio computer
di qualche tempo fa,
sono un po' più grande di voi -
ma soprattutto
qualche generazione di capelli fa
– questi erano i capelli
di qualche tempo fa. Li saluto.
E in quel momento
mi sono davvero reso conto
di quali fossero
le regole del gioco.
Soprattutto quelle non scritte.
Perché è lì
che mi sono reso conto
che al di là dei conti economici,
delle logiche produttive,
delle logiche industriali,
dei bilanci,
ogni realtà aziendale poggia,
in modo consapevole o meno,
su alcuni punti cardinali
di riferimento,
che sono i propri valori.
Ed è proprio di valori
che parleremo oggi.
Perché ci chiediamo:
quanto contano davvero i valori,
oggi, per competere?
Quanto possono incidere
nel modo di fare business?
Se guardiamo la classifica
The Most Admired Company 2015,
ai primi posti
troviamo aziende notissime,
come Apple, Google,
Amazon e via dicendo.
Oppure, ancora, la classifica
The World’s Most
Valuable Brands, di Forbes,
anche qua Apple, Microsoft,
Google, Coca-Cola.
Che cos’hanno in comune
tra di loro queste aziende,
al di là del fatto che sono
tra le più note al mondo?
Semplice: un solido sistema
di valori condiviso,
a cui tutti i collaboratori
fanno riferimento.
Si tratta di pilastri
che consentono alle persone
di gestire l’azienda
con uno stile di management,
che consente di avere
davvero “a bordo” le persone.
E che peraltro consente
di competere in modo più efficace.
Non serve però andare così lontano
da noi, per trovare esempi interessanti.
Infatti, se decidiamo di mettere
a fuoco le giuste cose,
si scopre che, molto più vicino
di quanto si pensi,
si possono trovare
i giusti messaggi.
Per quello, oggi mi piace condividere
un breve documento di 80 anni fa.
Il 28 ottobre 1935, a Campodarsego
- immaginate: un piccolo paese
della provincia a nord di Padova-
un imprenditore, nel consegnare
una macchina, scrive di suo pugno:
La seminatrice vendutavi
è garantita per due anni
tanto da diffetti
di materiale e di costruzione,
come da qualsiasi diffetto
di funzionamento.
In fede, Giovanni.
Chi lo farebbe oggi?
Lui ci mette la faccia.
È lui stesso che garantisce
prodotto e servizio.
E nel farlo dà
un fortissimo messaggio,
tanto ai propri clienti
quanto ai propri collaboratori.
Certo, siamo in un periodo storico
completamente diverso.
Siamo in un piccolo paese.
Si tratta di un mondo
in cui la relazione tra le persone,
dentro e fuori l’azienda,
conta più di ogni altra cosa.
Un mondo in cui i valori
– non condivisi perché
sono scritti o codificati,
ma condivisi nella prossimità,
vengono vissuti nella prossimità
e arrivano quasi per una sorta
di “osmosi valoriale”, a tutti i livelli.
1935.
Poi ovviamente
l’azienda cresce, e cambia.
Cambia nei linguaggi, cambia
nelle persone, cambia nelle strutture.
E soprattutto cambia
nelle logiche e nelle dinamiche.
Ed è proprio qui
che diventano determinanti i valori.
Perché si possono creare dei gap,
che a volte possono essere
difficili da colmare.
Quando ho cercato un’immagine che potesse
riassumere bene, velocemente,
il significato e la natura
di tali valori,
mi è venuto in mente un materiale
non usuale in ambito di management,
e chi fa consulenza
lo sa benissimo che non si usa:
la malta.
La cui funzione principale
non è tanto quella
di "incollare"
le componenti tra di loro,
quanto quella di distribuire il carico
e di compensare le asperità.
Fantastico.
Questo non ci fa venire in mente
le nostre organizzazioni?
I nostri bisogni?
E allora vediamo quale “malta”
usano le aziende di maggior successo,
ovvero quali sono
i loro valori di riferimento.
Quasi sempre si parla
di creazione di valore,
ancora di innovazione
- o, sempre più,
in un mondo che cambia,
in cui la responsabilità
diventa determinante,
proprio di responsabilità,
a tutti i livelli,
dentro e fuori l’azienda,
con la catena estesa del valore.
Ma soprattutto, trasversalmente,
si parla di persone.
E parliamo dunque di persone.
Facciamolo con un
semplicissimo grafico.
Tipicamente, in azienda,
per produrre si acquistano impianti.
Con un costo iniziale importante,
e un valore che nel tempo
è destinato a scendere.
Perché si svalutano, è normale.
Per le risorse umane, idealmente,
il percorso dovrebbe
essere qualcosa
di parallelo, distinto
e soprattutto opposto.
Perché una persona entra in azienda
senza alcuna competenza pratica
- e poi via via acquisisce ricchezza,
incrementando le proprie conoscenze.
E se, per gli impianti,
io mi adopero nel cambiare i pezzi,
nell’investire, nel fare manutenzione
- insomma nel far di tutto per prolungare
il ciclo di vita di ogni macchina,
per garantirne la produttività,
così anche per le persone
è fondamentale
pensare a un investimento,
a un sostegno.
Ma è di euro che stiamo parlando?
È di soldi?
È di rilancio economico?
È di remunerazione?
Se pensiamo che,
via via che passa il tempo,
la soluzione sia sempre quella
di rilanciare sul mero piano economico,
avremo giocoforza
a che fare con mercenari,
più interessati al premio
che al risultato.
Ci interessa davvero questo?
Piuttosto, e con questo concludo,
focalizziamoci su due parole-chiave.
La prima: ascolto.
Per le macchine esiste la diagnostica,
per capire come stanno nel tempo;
per le persone è fondamentale
un ascolto consapevole.
Facciamogli capire
che sono guardate, ascoltate, valutate,
e che anche a loro sono riconosciuti
i meriti lungo il percorso.
E poi manutenzione.
Nell’acquisto di una macchina,
di un impianto,
è compreso un programma
di manutenzione, certo.
Ma per le persone?
Anche qui è fondamentale
impostare un programma serio
di accompagnamento formativo,
che vada ben oltre le nozioni tecniche,
che non sono quelle
che ci risolvono i problemi.
Persone “ascoltate” e “manutenute”
saranno ben liete
di appartenere all’azienda,
e le daranno indietro valore
nel lungo periodo.
Poniamo dunque la persona al centro:
è questo il grande valore dei valori.
Grazie.
(Applausi)